president biden calls on everyone
vaccinated to mask again
the cdc links its masking case to a
coveted outbreak that killed zero people
and the biden economy is coming up short
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
[Music]
show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your data is your business
protected at expressvpn.com
slash ben we'll get to all the news in
just one moment first your reminder that
if you have one of the big wireless
providers you are spending
too much money on your cell phone bill
you should have switched over to
puretalk usa
long ago and many of my fans who already
have done this
have saved a lot of money they've got
the same great coverage because puretalk
is on the exact same network as one of
the big three but at any fraction
of the price in fact puretalk could save
your family over eight hundred dollars a
year
switching is as easy as switching out
your sim card you can keep your phone
keep your number or
get huge discounts on the latest iphones
and androids plus right now you can get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
for just 30 bucks a month
and if you go over on the data they're
not going to charge you for it there's a
reason pure talk is the highest rated
wireless company by consumer affairs
and why they are the preferred wireless
partner of amac
from your cell phone they'll pound 250
say ben shapiro save an additional 50
off your very first month that is two
five zero say my name ben shapiro to get
started save an additional 50
off your first month and hundreds of
dollars down the road again you don't
need one of the big wireless providers
to get the same
great coverage and also spend a fraction
of the money check them out right now
dial pal 250 say ben shapiro get started
with my friends at puretalk
usa okay so yesterday the president of
the united states
came out and said that it was time to
remask if you were fully vaccinated
so before we get to joe biden's actual
explanation of this nonsensical policy
let's start with what we know and what
we don't know at this point
here is what we know if you are
vaccinated you are very very very very
safe
from covid okay when i say very very
very safe what i mean is that 161
million people in the united states
have been vaccinated against covid of
those 161 million people
approximately 6 000 people have gotten
breakthrough cases requiring
hospitalization and about 1700 people
have died
this means that your chances of actually
being hospitalized with covid after
getting a vaccine are somewhere in the
neighborhood of one in 20
27 000 somewhere in that neighborhood
and your chances of death
after getting a vaccine are somewhere by
these statistics
around one in a hundred thousand okay
which means
that you're very very very very safe
from covet if you have been vaccinated
okay nothing that the cdc is now saying
changes
that simple fact and herein lies the
problem for everything that joe biden is
saying right now
if being vaccinated means you are very
safe from the virus
this means that even if you are capable
of transmitting the virus to the
unvaccinated
if every single adult in the united
states has had the opportunity to get
vaccinated
and then they don't and you infect them
that is their fault
not your fault it is not your job to
prevent somebody else
from getting a disease that they have
the ability to stop themselves from
being harmed by because they won't get a
vaccine and the idea that you're going
to require the vaccinated to mask up
to protect the unvaccinated is not even
asked for by the unvaccinated this is
the part that's crazy
okay the vaccinated are not in danger
from the unvaccinated
the unvaccinated are in danger from the
unvaccinated now we're learning that the
unvaccinated may be in some form of
danger from the vaccinated
what does this suggest well it suggests
the obvious solution which is the
unvaccinated should think very seriously
about getting vaccinated but they should
not require the kindness of strangers
in order to protect themselves they
should not require that small children
mask up in order to protect them they
should not require that people who have
already vaccinated mask up in order to
protect them this is nonsensical in fact
if you want to encourage people to get
vaccinated
instead of requiring that the vaccinated
mask up you should do precisely
the opposite the biden administration
seems to be
operating under the assumption that
there is a link
between mask mandates and vaccination
encouragement that if you push mass
mandates
you can also push vaccination
encouragement at the same time
push people to wear masks but also push
them to get vaccinated this
is nonsensical for a variety of reasons
first because
very often when people hear mass
mandates what they think instinctively
is oh the vaccines must not be working
you're seeing a lot of that over the
past 24-48 hours from people who are
unlikely to get the vaccine anyway
people saying well you know we were told
that the vaccines were a cure-all and
now you're telling us that the
vaccinated are still passing this thing
off so what else aren't you telling us
about the vaccines
so that's number one number two people
will start to think that the masks are
actually a good way of protecting people
when it comes to delta the evidence that
the masks are very effective in
protecting people
is pretty skimpy according to scott
gottlieb over at the fda as we'll get to
in a second
and finally let's even assume that
masking the vaccinated lowers the rates
of transmission to people who are
unvaccinated
that does not encourage the unvaccinated
to get vaccinated it encourages them to
mask up and rely on everybody else to
mask up which means that no one is ever
going to unmask for the rest of human
history
so none of this makes any sort of
logical sense now let's go through the
data that prompted this change in heart
okay so the cdc mask decision according
to the abc news
followed a stunning finding from a cape
cod beach outbreak
okay this is literally as we'll see
pretty much the only piece of evidence
that the cdc is relying upon
is that over the fourth of july a big
crowd went to cape cod
and a bunch of people infected each
other and it turns out that a large
number of those people were fully
immunized
as of thursday according to abc news 882
people were tied to the provincetown
outbreak
among those living in massachusetts 74
were fully immunized yet officials said
the vast majority were also reporting
symptoms
now here is the thing how many of those
people got seriously ill
like really seriously ill not like they
got cold symptoms like they got really
really sick
out of the 882. seven people
were hospitalized seven now remember
your chances of actually getting a
symptomatic breakthrough
remain pretty damn low so this does not
mean that one out of every 100 people
who's vaccinated is going to end up
hospitalized this means that one out of
every even according to these stats okay
less than one out of every 100 people
who is infected with covid after being
vaccinated which is a fraction of a
fraction now
is going to be hospitalized and how many
of these people have died
zero zero so you're seeing the cdc
recommend that every vaccinated person
in the united states all 161 million of
them
mask up because there was an outbreak in
cape cod that resulted in zero
deaths and this is what you're seeing
across the country you got dc
that is now recommending that everybody
mask up again
los angeles recommending that everybody
mask up again indoors
how many deaths deon day is los angeles
county having
again a county of 10 million people the
answer is nine
how many day on day deaths is washington
dc having that requires an indoor mass
mandate
the answer is zero eleven people
have been shot and killed in washington
dc since the last time somebody died of
covet in washington dc you are now more
likely to die of being murdered
in washington dc like on the street
than you are to die of covet in
washington dc and they are going back to
mass mandates
anyway okay so the province town
outbreak is apparently sort of the key
here and then the washington post
reports
on this new cdc sort of report it was a
cdc
slide deck that they put out and the
slide deck
is not particularly edifying and so
we're going to go through some of the
slide deck
right now so let's begin with with what
they say about the delta varian which is
supposedly this giant game changer so
what they say
is number one that people are still
evidencing after vaccination that if
they if they have a breakthrough case
remember according to this slide deck as
we will see your chance of getting a
breakthrough
case period have been lowered by about
two-thirds if you are if you're
vaccinated
in other words you're significantly less
likely to get a breakthrough case even
of the delta variant if you're
vaccinated
okay but what they say in the case they
make is that the viral load that you are
carrying meaning the amount of virus in
your
in your nasopharyngeal pharyngeal
passage in your nose basically
the the amount of virus that you are
carrying is similar to the unvaccinated
the study they are relying upon is an
indian indian study that was already
retracted and was based
on a vaccine that is not legal in the
united states
and they kind of admit this on page 16
of this slide quote
india report of lower cycle threshold
values in delta breakthrough cases
the lower your cycle threshold value is
the more virus essentially you have
compared to non-delta breakthrough cases
also larger cluster size with delta
breakthrough they say the delta
infection is associated with a longer
duration of having
the the virus in your body as opposed to
the alpha strain for example
and there may be a higher risk of
reinfection but only if you had an
infection more than six months ago okay
so all of this is rooted in this india
study and this is the only study they
cite to this effect
that india study was already retracted
it was based on a vaccine that we're not
allowed to use in the united states
so questionable at best questionable
best okay then
they get some more viral load
information and they suggest that
it says at the bottom of this
preliminary data subject to change okay
so this is all
pretty dicey stuff they say breakthrough
cases reported to national passive
surveillance
have lower ct values cycle threshold
values
by three cycles a tenfold increase in
viral load for delta
compared with alpha so again they're
saying that you have a higher viral load
compared with alpha
but that's not really this particular
stat is not really comparing the
vaccinated and the unvaccinated which
they say
are similar the only piece of data that
they present outside of the
the indian study here are data from barn
stable county massachusetts right this
is this outbreak that we're talking
about in cape cod
they said there's no difference in mean
cycle threshold values in vaccinated and
unvaccinated cases
it's saying that they now they haven't
actually done vaccine culture they
haven't actually done
viral load cultures here so it's unclear
they make an assumption the assumption
is
if the amount of virus in the nose of an
unvaccinated person is the same as the
amount of virus in the nose of a
vaccinated person they transmit the
disease in similar fashion
now that might be a fair assumption but
it is clearly an assumption it is also
possible
that the amount of virus in a vaccinated
person's nose has been affected in some
way because
that person is vaccinated perhaps their
shedding virus that is
less lethal perhaps their shedding virus
that is dead
right it is not clear because none of
this has been cultured
right so this is part of the problem
okay then you get to
the the only chart in this whole thing
that really matters okay as far as logic
the only chart that matters
okay here are the charts uh fives are
two dose vaccine efficacy
for alpha versus data versus delta alpha
is the original strain that was going
around the world the european strain
delta is the current strain that people
are very much afraid of okay here's what
it shows
it shows in england and scotland that
the
pfizer vaccine is still 79
effective at preventing infection okay
so before it was over 90
against alpha it's still about 80
effective at preventing infection
it is still 88 effective at preventing
symptomatic disease
and it is still 96 effective at
preventing hospitalization
okay that last number is the one that
matters because that's the one you care
about gang
i don't care how many people every year
in the united states are diagnosed with
the flu if nobody dies of the flu
i only care how many people are dying of
a disease if no one is dying of a
disease it is of no public health
relevance to us
at all at all okay the same thing is
true in canada
in canada alpha versus delta
the the vaccines are performing very
well against symptomatic disease in
canada
and right now they've had zero deaths
attributable to delta in canada
in israel right which has had this vast
sort of post-delta outbreak
israel currently is showing a 64 percent
protection against confirmed infection
right so that's a lot lower than the 90
against confirmed alpha infection
but 64 still means that
basically in 60 not basically in 64 out
of 100 cases where you have the
pfizer two-dose vaccine you're going to
avoid being infected with delta
64 effective against symptomatic
disease but again we don't care about
symptomatic disease what we care about
is hospitalization or death
okay hospitalization or death 93
effective against delta compared with
about 94
effective against alpha so in other
words these vaccines are extremely
effective in preventing hospitalization
and death which last time i checked is
the main job of the vaccine
okay now we get to the masking portion
of what the cdc suggests
there are many problems with what the
cdc suggests here in terms of masking
so number one they assume natural
immunity
is about five percent okay or about 35
percent now it's possible natural
immunity is much higher that many many
more people have had this
than the cdc is willing to contemplate
in fact
they they created these models showing
how many people will likely be
hospitalized and die
or or the probability of the increase in
caseload based on natural immunity
numbers
the big the big problem here is the
model assumptions which they list
here in the cdc report so they assume
the vaccine effectiveness
in preventing transmissibility is
somewhere between 75 and 85 okay fair
enough looking at the foreign data
that's fair enough
then they assume that we have had 50 of
infections reported
in the united states at this time this
is wildly incorrect
there is no way that 50 of the
infections in the united states have
been reported
ever at any time in the united states
okay the reality is
the vast majority of infections already
prevalent in the united states probably
have not been
reported scott gottlieb former fda
commissioner says this is an utterly
unreasonable assumption
completely unreasonable how many people
out there who are vaccinated for example
have had cold symptoms right i've had a
cold symptom i've been tested
because i have cold symptoms and i'm
vaccinated and until the last five
minutes
the cdc was saying that i was protected
against covid
even being even being symptomatic from
it okay so
50 of infections have been reported
according to the cdc
wrong it is completely wrong which is
why scott gottlieb says we may be much
closer to the other side
of this peak than the cdc is letting on
other assumptions they make that are
wrong they assume that for masking
masking is going to be incredibly
effective they assume that source
control meaning
your ability to infect others
then masking prevents that by 40 to 60
percent
now all of the data that they gathered
on masking efficacy
were always very shoddy these were
always very shoddy not real world data
but
even assuming that those data were
correct the source control 40 to 60
effective this is again scott gottlieb
saying that's not me
those numbers come from control of the
flu the flu virus
is much less transmissible than delta
which is now apparently as transmissible
as chickenpox
so it is quite possible source control
from masks is way lower than 40 to 60
especially depending on the type of mask
metal cloth mask it's way lower than
that
using personal protection is 20 to 30
percent effective
okay so masking in other words is not
necessarily going to do very much here
and as we've already seen in the uk you
don't need a mask mandate in order to
come down the other side of this
particular hill
okay meanwhile they also assume by the
way that there will be no adjustments
for other intervention interventions
meaning that
nobody in the united states is going to
stop going out and stop partying and
stop doing what they're doing which of
course is very silly because when people
feel there's an uptick in their
community from coveted and they're
unvaccinated
data show they tend to get vaccinated or
they tend to
stay home or they tend to not go to big
gatherings
okay so those are all the assumptions
with regard to masking of
efficacy they also make some assumptions
about immunity
again those assumptions about immunity
are not particularly
i would say compelling and then finally
they make their recommendations
and the recommendations according to the
cdc is they say communications
acknowledge
the war has changed except the war has
not changed
this thing is just moving faster that's
all that's all that's really that's all
that's changed the thing's moving faster
improve public's understanding of
breakthrough infections improve
communications around individual risk
among vaccinated
risk of severe disease or death reduced
ten-fold or greater and vaccinated
risk of infection reduced to three-fold
in vaccinated
prevention and here's where they get to
where they're going to tell you what to
do consider vaccine mandates
for for hcp to protect vulnerable
populations
so vaccine mandates for healthcare
providers
okay again i don't actually think that
one is particularly
either burdensome or unreasonable
considering that healthcare providers
are dealing with people with
underlying conditions nearly all the
time they also recommend universal
masking for source control and
prevention
they've not provided the data that
supports this or even the ideological
and logical rationale for this
and reconsider other community
mitigation strategies so now
they are opening the door to new
lockdowns they're doing all of this
based on the fact
that we have a very low level of death
in the united states
right now from covid right now again i'm
going to keep reading these day on day
averages because the stats still
matter to me the day-on-day average of
7-day death in the united states is 320.
320 people approximately die every day
in the united states of alzheimer's i'm
going to keep saying that because you
need to understand
what these numbers mean in context in
the context of covid this means we've
reduced the death rate in the united
states by a factor
of approximately 10 since the height of
the pandemic that is thanks to the
vaccines
and compared to other causes of death in
the united states like for example heart
disease about 1800 people a day in the
united states die of heart disease about
300 people a day are currently dying of
covid
and now they're recommending universal
masking again and maybe lockdowns
okay this is madness it's not oriented
toward reality
it's just crazy towns it's just crazy
towns and again
if the idea here is that you need a mass
mandate in order to hit the peak let me
show you this chart from the uk
the uk was in the middle of the death of
varians about two weeks before we were
the uk hit their height about a week ago
as you can see from this chart they've
been plummeting
in the past week none of our magical
health experts seem to be able to
explain any of this
they don't seem to be able to explain
any of this so in other words
the methods that are now being
undertaken by the biden administration
and by blue states all over the country
they don't make any form of logical
sense even if you concede
based on the skimpy data available even
if you concede
that breakthrough infections of be
vaccinated
are capable of higher transmission that
still does not result in universal mass
mandates
it doesn't the logical gap is just not
bridge
it isn't then joe biden comes out and um
and he announces this policy and again
he undermines his own policy because
none of this makes any internal logical
sense
he starts off by saying breakthrough
cases are rare okay if breakthrough
cases are rare
then what in the world are you talking
about max masking vaccinated for
here's joe biden many of you who are
vaccinated are concerned about what's
called
breakthrough cases yes some fully
vaccinated people will still
test positive and some will show some
symptoms of cova-19 that's expected with
almost every vaccine there is
for other diseases but breakthrough
cases remain
rare and almost all are mild cases
in fact virtually all hospitalizations
and deaths
are among the unvaccinated
okay so if that is true then what are
you talking about
by the way further note now i mentioned
earlier on that a lot of what they're
talking about in terms of
the vaccinated spreading this thing and
they're talking about provincetown
cape cod that's party central and that
is like
the most efficient method for spreading
virus as josh barrow points out
nate silver says whether it's true or
not of provincetown per se
the bigger problem is that you don't
want to make extrapolations from
outliers but that's exactly what the cdc
is now doing so joe biden then continues
he says even if you're fully vaccinated
you could theoretically have the delta
variant in your system and pass it on to
others
the cdc recommends you wear a mask when
you're in public
and indoors like work or in a grocery
store
that's true for both the vaccinated and
the unvaccinated why
because even if you've been fully
vaccinated and protected from severe
illness from covet 19 you could have the
delta variant in your system
and spread it to someone who isn't
vaccinated okay so
if that's your chief worry is that i the
vaccinated person i'm going to pass it
to you the unvaccinated person
wouldn't that encourage you the
unvaccinated person to get the vaccine
why joe biden still has not yet
explained why it is a good incentive
structure
to force be vaccinated to mask up to
protect the unvaccinated
when the unvaccinated are fully capable
of making decisions for themselves they
are adults and they get to decide
whether they want to take the vaccine or
not and it's available to them at any
publix anywhere in the united states
we'll get to more of this nonsensical
policy in just one second by the way
it's going
it's absolutely going to come back in by
biden if he thinks there's a winner for
him he's he's
totally wrong we'll get some more of
this in just one second first
we've got a very different kind of
sponsor for this particular episode the
jordan
harbinger show which is a podcast you
really should be listening to i know
that every day somebody tells you you
just have to listen to some podcast and
you nod you say sure
and then you never listen to it well
don't let that happen here
jordan's show which apple named one of
its best of 2018 is aimed at making you
a better informed more critical thinker
so you get a sense of how the world
actually works and come to your own
conclusions about what's happening even
inside your own brain
each episode is a conversation with a
different fascinating guest in one
episode jordan talks to a hostage
negotiator from the fbi
who offers techniques on how to get
people to like and trust you
which is both edifying and interesting
and also somewhat disturbing
another reason to support jordan
harbinger the woke mob has been going
after him these days because his show
has a bunch of diverse opinion makers on
it and teaches people
how to think versus what's a thing go
check out the show it's really enjoyable
we here at the daily wire enjoy it we
think you will too
there's a lot more here check out
jordanharbinger.com
start for some episode recommendations
or search for the jordan harbinger show
that's h
a r b as in boy i n is in nancy g e r
on apple podcast spotify or wherever you
listen to podcasts alrighty so
joe biden then lays it out he says you
need to wear a mask in order to protect
the unvaccinated that's why you're going
to be wearing a mouse gang
we need to wear a mask to protect each
other and to stop the rapid spread of
this virus
as we work to get more people vaccinated
i hope all americans who live in areas
with substantial or high cases rates
will follow the mass guidance that's
being laid down by the cdc
i certainly will and i have because this
is one of those areas in washington
okay by the way rashel willenski has
been saying the same thing
she says quote on in rare occasions some
vaccinated people infected
with the delta variants after
vaccination may be contagious and spread
the virus to others
oh so we're just going to vax again
you're talking about masking up
hundreds of millions of people at this
point based on
circumstances that have been defined by
the cdc director
as somewhat rare the only data that have
been presented are a breakout case in
provincetown
and an indian study that has not been
verified yet
but even if you accept all that the
incentive structures still make no sense
so joe biden was asked to explain why he
changed his standards on
post-vaccination and masking and here he
is not being able to explain himself of
course
in may you made it sound like a vaccine
with the ticket to losing the mass
forever
that getting vaccinated made a gigantic
difference
and what happened was the new variant
came along
they didn't get vaccinated it was spread
more rapidly
and people more people were getting sick
that's the difference
okay well that's not actually the
difference the unvaccinated are in just
as much danger as they ever were
the vaccinated are in just as little
danger as they ever were so actually the
calculus did not change
the only thing that changed here is that
everybody panic
that's what changed here by the way
biden did say that right he said if
you're a vaccinated unmask right this
was joe biden just a couple of months
ago
it's vaxxed or masked
that by the way is is a lot more
coherent than what he's saying now
you'll recall that last year by the way
joe biden it's now been a year since
this joe biden
said last year quote i'm not going to
shut down the country
i'm not going to shut down the economy
i'm going to shut down
the virus oh really then why won't your
white house rule out further lockdowns
yesterday one of the white house press
secretaries came out and explained that
the white house would not be ruling out
for their lockdowns
if scientists come to you at some point
down the line and say
it is our opinion that there should be
shutdowns and there should be school
closures
you would do that well we listened to
like i said we listened to the cdc and
the the expert and the
and their guidance um are you know are
the cdc is a is a body that is very well
respected
and uh we found again we follow their
guidance the cdc is not a body that is
well respected it is not all respected
by me it is not well respected by people
who watch the cdc
i do not respect the cdc they've changed
their guidance 1000 times not based on
good data but based on this
sort of panicked squirrel-like
consistence that every new outlier case
is a rationale for public lockdowns and
masked mandates without any sort of
actual understanding
of how the human mind works or how
people act
this is madness it's absolutely crazy by
the way even the the mandates that are
now being announced by biden
even though those don't make any sort of
internal logical sense so joe biden
yesterday announced that federal
employees
are going to have to get vaccinated or
they're going to have to test
like every week so here's what job i
need to say
every federal government employee will
be asked to attest
to their vaccination status anyone who
does not attest
or is not vaccinated will be required to
mask no matter where they work test
one or two times a week to see if
they've they've acquired
covet socially distanced
and generally will not be allowed to
travel for work
okay so um let's just note something
they said that they're going to be
tested like once a week
that's completely ineffective you test
people for code once a week
what happens in the intervening week
what if they test
negative on monday and then they have
covet on tuesday wednesday thursday
friday saturday or sunday
so no this this doesn't make any sense
at all like at all
but it's not meant to make sense it's
not meant to be related to reality
it's meant to create a forever reliance
on government with no actual endpoint
i've been saying this for weeks at this
point
there is no end goal there's no end goal
if your end goal is zero covet it's
because you're a fool no one
seriously believes that zero covet is a
serious goal it's not
to pretend that zero covet is is
reachable or attainable
is contra all available science at this
point and yet that seems to be what
they're going for
because obviously we're not worried
about overwhelming hospitals nobody's
even mentioned that
we're not even worried about getting
people availability of the vaccine
all we're worried about right now is
this idea that we have to have zero
cover zero covet is not a real goal but
it's the only goal that would make any
sense of what they're trying to do right
now
alrighty so the the trust us brigade is
here
and they they don't actually provide any
rationale for what it is
that they are doing as admiral brett
jarrar said on fox news yesterday
there's no transparency there's weak
data why exactly are we supposed to
trust these folks
my major concern is we had a incredibly
important policy announcement
by the cdc to recommend math scoring
even for those who are vaccinated
but they have supplied zero data no
transparency
no information why is that
because i don't i think they don't
really have the data or the data a week
dr wilinski said
in rare circumstances a vaccinated
person
may transmit well if it's one percent
point one percent
point zero one percent there's no reason
for the mask
recommendations but we don't know
because they won't tell us
that dr gerard is of course former
assistant secretary for health
in the trump administration meanwhile
another doctor on msnbc and this really
does
i think summarize the conflict in the
country uh this
this doctor on msnbc dr patel she says
that we have to believe walensky and
fauci we have to
right or alternatively we could check
out the data they present see whether it
is weak or strong and then determine
whether they are even recommending
anything remotely resembling sensical
public policy
but really this is what it's come down
to we have to trust them we have we must
there's no question that cdc is one of
the premier authorities on top of data
and science and
we have to believe exactly what dr
volinsky dr fauci said when they're
seeing concerning signs that people who
are
fully vaccinated are at a risk of
transmitting this virus not getting sick
and
dying but transmitting this especially
to half the country that's unvaccinated
okay
this is just all they want is a
continuation that's the only rationale
here they like
they must like the control they must
love it
it's all paternalistic by the way i
don't think it's any coincidence that
joe biden has now announced that he
wishes to
congress to extend the federal eviction
moratorium
okay the cdc more the cdc put what is
probably an illegal moratorium on
eviction of tenants
i was not aware that the cdc is anywhere
granted legislative power to prevent
people from evicting tenants who don't
pay their rent
okay the vaccines have now been widely
available since march and april
we still have prevented people from
being evicted from their apartments for
not paying rent
now joe biden wants that extended
according to the wall street journal
president biden would have strongly
supported a move to further extend
the cdc moratorium scheduled to expire
on saturday
that option is no longer legally viable
after a recent supreme court ruling the
administration said in a statement
by press secretary jensaki
state and local governments have
struggled to distribute 47 billion in
federal money aimed at helping tenants
who can't pay rent
because of the pandemic triggered
downturn leaving many people at risk of
being forced out of their homes when the
moratorium expires
just 3 billion of that aid has even been
delivered good news joe biden is going
to be um
shoveling more cash out the doors we're
going to discuss in in just one moment
but but the fact that the the biden
administration continuously wants these
big spending programs that they need an
excuse for it they need some sort of
lever
in order to do all of it is disquieting
so the blowback has begun
i think it is a serious blowback i think
that people are really not going to
stand for this in the blue states they
will because in the blue states
masking up has been a sign of compliance
it has been a sign that you are
the gold star a plus third grade student
who brings an apple to the teacher
your authorities told you to do
something and you are going to stand and
cheer
and you are not going to be the first
person to sit down that is the attitude
that seems prevalent in places
like los angeles county which let me
remind you
la county has a total of 10 million
people living in it
and their seven day rolling death rate
is nine
is nine they've massed up the entire
county again
the same thing is going to happen in new
york where the rolling death rate is in
single digits
all of you i guess you're more virtuous
you're just virtu like the amount of
virtue is just incredible
incredible virtue because if you do what
your authoritarian leaders tell you to
do
well this means that you're a very very
virtuous person obviously well the
blowback is beginning here
so in the house of representatives nancy
pelosi has
has put forward a mass mandate again
based on nothing
last i checked every single senator in
the united states senate has had the
vaccine
when it comes to the house a bunch of
republicans have apparently not had the
vaccine
that's on them that is their decision if
they wish to bear the consequences of
getting kovid and not having a vaccine
that's their problem because again
here's the magic of the vaccine
once you've had it you're extremely safe
from covid
by all available data including
including the new cdc data
okay so nancy pelosi announced this a
bunch of masculine republicans were like
fine arrest us
this is them marching into the house
mask list
and nancy pelosi of course has
threatened to arrest them all
which of course is not tin pot dictator
kind of stuff in any way shape or form
okay meanwhile kevin mccarthy came out
and said these these standards that
pelosi is promulgating are nonsensical
she called him a
and then tim ryan the democrat from ohio
did one of his usual
sort of barn burning speeches in which
he in which he ripped and mccarthy for
mocking
the magical mask the most incredible of
all masks
somebody in this chamber is coming from
a hot spot
somebody represents the hot spots
and they get in a plane and they fly
here and they interact with all of us
i just find it absolutely immature
and appalling to somehow diminish it
to try to score cheap political points
and that's exactly what we saw
a few minutes ago that is beneath
a minority leader of one of the major
political parties
in the united states of america how dare
you mock the masked mandate
this mask this very mask
okay let me explain you know what's
going to protect you
not the mask what's going to protect you
is the vaccine
that's what's going to protect you the
vaccine doesn't mean masks don't work
we don't know how well they work end of
story
what we do know is that vaccines do work
to prevent death and if you choose not
to get it you're an adult at one point
like it really does come down to sort of
a the reason this is broken down left
right
is because for so many people on the
right at a certain point they say listen
you're an adult what you do is on you
and for the left
it's we think you're a and we're
going to control everything that you do
and even if you do what we say you're a
and we're going to control
everything you do and if you don't do
what we say you're a and we're
going to control
everything that you do and if you're on
the right you're like listen now that
the solution's available you're on your
own
be an adult make good decisions gang
but that is not something the left can
ever allow which is why they are so
they're more adamant than teams this
time than they were last time
which is wild okay we'll get to so ron
desantis
uh the governor of florida who of course
is coming under renewed
fire because he said we're not doing
mass mandates in the state of florida
quite properly
well by the way wildly encouraging
vaccines
and i don't know what the media does
about this because desantis has been
extremely pro-vaccine
since the very beginning he was one of
the the best governors in terms of
tranching this thing out to the elderly
in the state of florida
so here's ron desantis yesterday saying
no we're not we're not going to do this
this faucian
dystopia routine floridians are free to
choose and all americans should be free
to choose
how they govern their affairs how they
take care of themselves and our families
and they should not be consigned to live
regardless of which state in the union
consigned to live in a faucian dystopia
in which we're governed
by the whims of bureaucratic authorities
who
care little for our freedom little for
our aspirations
and little for our happiness no more
we can't let it happen going forward
this is correct
and that's going to be the choice
because i have a feeling this is going
to contain like i put out a poll
yesterday on twitter how long is this
crap going to continue
because really there's no end point we
could be down to one case of covid in
the entire united states and they will
still be saying mask up because after
all somebody could get infected you
never know there's another variant
around the corner so the question is
what is the endpoint the left has no
endpoint and so this leads me to believe
that this is going to be an ongoing
issue for the next couple of years
this leads me to believe that they are
never gonna let this sucker go
which which really in the end means that
this will turn
into well we'll have an election based
on it 2022 may be based on this
maybe even 2024. alrighty in just a
second we're going to get to the other
issue
that is going to be coming up in 2022
and 2024 and that is the faltering
economy
first it can be overwhelming to perform
at your best as you age you got career
family staying in shape life can get
stressful you start to slow down you're
not present
when you want to be to perform at your
best both physically and mentally you
can't let age beat you and this is where
m drive can help
m drive is the daily supplement for
driven men who don't want to slow down
who refuse to be tired every day who
want to be the best at what they do
it's packed with clinically tested
ingredients that support healthy
testosterone levels while helping you
lose weight and stay lean
adding vitamins nutrients reduce stress
and boost your drive so you can perform
at your best find it at walgreens and
other retailers or
visit mdrive4men.com and get 20 off your
very first
order with promo code ben have free
shipping a 60-day money-back guarantee
so you've got nothing
to lose m drive it's not for everyone
it's for the driven mdrive4men.com
promo code ben if you feel low on that
energy level and you want to hit the gas
pedal a little bit
head on over to mdrive4men.com get 20
off your first order with promo code ben
and of course they have the free
shipping and the 60 day money back
guarantee
so you really have nothing to lose that
is mdrive4men.com
alrighty folks the cdc of course is now
recommending that vaccinated individuals
wear masks indoors of course because
this is this is what we're just gonna do
until the end of time
but bad news for you good news for the
book because the book i wrote is all
about the authoritarian moment through
which we are now living
the fact that the scientific authorities
have been twisted by the left into
promulgators of bad science and
left-wing politics
for example pick up my book the
authoritarian moment it talks
about how every major institution in our
society has been weaponized
by the left the authoritarian moment is
now available at amazon barnes and noble
or any other major
bookseller go get your copy right now
leave a five-star review to let others
know
that this book is worth their time as
well it also gives some solutions as to
how we fight back
also if you've watched backstage and
thought it would be cool to be a part of
it i'm here to tell you about something
unbelievably cool
when you join the daily wire with code
backstage you get 25
off your membership and you're
automatically entered to win a trip to
visit the daily wire here in nashville
you can meet me
and the other daily warehouse tour our
studios and offices get a great swag bag
of merch
and watch the show live so if you're not
a member yet
this might just be the best time to
become one head on over to dailywire.com
backstage use code backstage to get 25
off your new membership and
be automatically entered to win not one
but two tickets to chat it up with us
that is dailywire.com backstage use code
backstage to get 25
off your new membership you're listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
meanwhile the biden administration is
struggling because the reality
of the biden administration is they need
a successful economy in order to
ram through their gigantic spending
agenda at least in popular fashion
well the economy is beginning to
stagnate the u.s economy
grew at about 6.5 percent in q2
there's only one problem virtually all
economists thought it was going to grow
at 8.5
and if you recall just a couple of
months ago they thought it was going to
grow in excess of 10
so it is not growing at the rate that
they want it to grow that's not stopping
the media from feigning enthusiasm
you've got cnn business
saying the u.s economy in the second
quarter expanded at a slower rate than
expected but still
its fastest pace since last fall growing
at a seasonally adjusted annualized rate
of 6.5 percent
their headline by the way at cnn
businesses u.s economy just posted the
largest jump in growth since 2020.
uh yeah that's not the headline the
headline is not the largest jump in
growth since 2020.
the headline is you missed your mark by
in terms of real gdp the economy has now
recovered and that it has grown bigger
than its pre-pandemic size but does
anyone feel
that the economy is really at that rate
the answer is no because
gdp is being racked up by government
spending
it's being held up by the amount of
government spending that's being done
the the national bureau of economic
research designated the pandemic
recession as the shortest on record
saying it lasted just two months march
and april of 2020 which is when the
shutdowns were
in normal time says cnn business 6.5
growth
would be a reason to celebrate it's
still pretty good performance but
it's disappointment compared with the
8.5 growth rate economist had forecast
it was only a little change from the
first quarter when the economy grew an
annual rate of 6.3
which by the way is kind of amazing
because you'll remember that something
happened between the first quarter of
this year and the second quarter of this
year
namely the mass vaccination of americans
and yet nothing is changing
which suggests two things one the biden
administration's constant drum beat of
doom and gloom
with regard to the future of the virus
and their unwillingness to acknowledge
that the pandemic no longer has public
health ramifications
means that people are staying home and
two when you pay people to stay
home and then spend trillions of dollars
on nonsensical crap
you end up actually subjecting the us
economy to headwinds that it can't fully
overcome
according to cnn itself the acceleration
in the recovery was spurred
was spurred by consumer spending not
least spurred by the last round of
stimulus checks
as well as the reopening of the economy
and continued vaccination consumers
spent more on services particularly on
dining out and traveling
driven by the same dynamics measures of
inflation through
rose throughout the spring for example
the price index that tracks personal
consumption
rose to 6.4 in the second quarter that
was its highest level
since 1982 since 1982
even if you strip out the more volatile
items like food and energy the price
index was at 6.1 percent
the highest reading since 1983 and
here's the thing the federal reserve
cannot can they do not have the stones
to actually jack up the interest rates
in a way necessary to cut down on the
inflation they're not going to do it
not when the economy is this slow if the
economy is not faster than this
see if the economy really really if we
were like 8.5 growth or something
then they could say listen we're growing
super fast natural economic recovery is
happening we need to raise the interest
rates a little bit to prevent
overheating and to prevent price
inflation
instead because the economy is growing
slower than expected
they are going to continue to rack up
quantitative easing they're going to
continue
to jack money into the economy and keep
the interest rates at zero
out of fear that they're going to sink
joe biden's economic record here
meanwhile the democrats are so
disconnected from reality that they're
worried that joe biden isn't spending
enough
according to the hill democrats are now
warning that any attempts by moderates
to pare down a 3.5 trillion dollar
spending package
could threaten president biden's top
legislative priority and leave the party
empty-handed so joe biden wants to get
everything done in his
budget package he's got the the
bipartisan infrastructure bill the
trillion dollar
boondoggle which is at least better than
the 2 trillion
boondoggle they're originally proposing
now it's a trillion dollar boondoggle
which still sucks but is better than the
alternative presumably
then they have their giant budget
package that giant budget package the
3.5 trillion
budget package as you will recall has
been held up by kristen
cinema in the in the senate as well as
joe manchin both of whom look at this
and they're saying this is too much
money
now you've got democrats in the senate
saying we're not going to vote for the
infrastructure package
if you don't vote for the for the 3.5
trillion
package and not just that joe biden now
is saying that he wants
immigration reform in the budget package
meaning he wants to legalize
some eight to 10 million illegal
immigrants in the united states in the
budget reconciliation package
by the way the parliamentarian hasn't
even said if you can do that under
budget reconciliation the answer is
probably not but
who the hell knows progressive democrats
are sounding the alarm after kristen
sinema warned wednesday she doesn't
support the 3.5 trillion dollar price
tag
for the expansive package democrats hope
to muscle through biden is saying he's
basically negotiating
with her he thinks she'll end up voting
for it in the end but they may have to
cut a few things
democrats hope to move the legislation
on party lines in the senate with
special budgetary rules but
every democrat because there are only 50
of them every democrat can hold this
thing up with one vote
progressives are saying they're going to
hold up the infrastructure plan unless
they get the 3.5 trillion dollar plan
bernie sanders said it's my absolute
conviction you're not going to have a
bipartisan bill
unless you have a reconciliation bill of
3.5 trillion dollars
so as we discussed yesterday joe biden
is now stuck between the progressive
rock and the moderate hard place right
now
the republicans aren't going to vote in
favor of that bipartisan
infrastructure plan at all unless the
democrats pared down the 3.5 trillion
plan and the progressives won't vote for
the bipartisan plan
or the or the budget plan unless they
continue to have it at 3.5 trillion
dollars
sanders says he expects the spending
plan to be 3.5 trillion in the senate
maybe even more
in the house and senator chris murphy of
connecticut adds that any push to
decrease the price tag for the spending
package would make it hard to get the
votes
for it man the democrats are just
cruising for a bruising in 2022 on all
fronts whether we were talking about
these
authoritarian lockdown measures
completely nonsensical or whether we're
talking about the vast
spending that is resulting in reduced
and tamped down economic growth
they're just cruising for it in 2022
which is why they're so focused in as
always on trump and january 6th because
2022 is looking to be an
ugly year for them 2024 could be even
worse especially if kamal harris is on
the ballot
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content first
you can't forget to end your week by
checking out the edward clavin show
drew's shows every friday he's got an
exciting evening planned for you so head
on over to dailywire.com 7 pm eastern 6
pm central
tune in i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo wiedowsky
associate producer bradford carrington
host producer justin barber the show is
edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
john bickley here editor-in-chief of
daily wire wake up every morning with
our new show
morning wire on today's episode
president biden addresses immigration
and crime countries around the world
loosen their travel restrictions
and democrats push for student loan
forgiveness join us and get the facts
first on the news you need to know with
our show
morning wire
you